eh bien me revoilà encore une fois je
m'excuse
vous avez eu l'occasion de me voir six
sept huit fois en une après-midi vous
avez réussi à le supporter est plutôt
bien félicitations c'est rare les
personnes qui résiste à ce genre de
choses
ce qui me dérange un peu
c'est que j'ai vu certains d'entre vous
se dire tiens la première fois que je
les ai vus ils avaient l'air plein
d'énergie la deuxième fois il avait
l'air tout mou et déprimé la troisième
fois il est parti complètement à l'ouest
il réveille voulait traverser
l'atlantique mais vous êtes dit celui là
il est en train de nous mentir
celui là il fait semblant d'être
plusieurs personnes c'est possible c'est
possible peut-être que je vous ment mais
est ce qu'on m'en tirais pas tous un peu
finalement
est ce que vous êtes toujours la même
personne quelle que soit la situation
quelles que soient les gens que vous
côtoyez non si je mens je ne suis pas le
seul à m'en tire toi aussi tu m'en
voudrais aussi là bas vous mentez oui et
toute la dernière rangée d'ailleurs oui
parce que lorsque vous êtes avec votre
petite amie ou votre petit copain vous
avez tendance à le dire une chose assez
simple au bébé c'est toi que j'aime le
plus au monde
mais c'est vrai quand vous le dites vous
le pensez enfin je l'espère mais quand
vous voyez votre mère qu'est ce que vous
lui dites oh maman c'est toi qui m'as
mis au monde
c'est toi que j'aime le plus au monde
bizarre ça fait déjà 2 alors avec vos
amis là c'est encore pire
qu'est ce que je ferais sans vous olala
j'en peux plus
oh non parce que ma copine elle est
vraiment génial mais où
et voilà c'est maintenant vos amis que
vous aimez le plus au monde étrange vous
aussi vous avez changé de personnalité
vous aussi vous êtes différent alors
quand on arrive à ce point là on se pose
une petite question
finalement qu'est ce que vraiment la
personnalité la personnalité il ya
beaucoup de définitions
moi j'aime bien l'idée que la
personnalité c'est la capacité à
exprimer un sentiment c'est à dire que
vous avez la colère la rage
l'humour l'amour tous ces sentiments ils
sont en vous et certains d'entre vous
les ressentent plus ou moins fort
certains d'entre vous les expriment plus
ou moins fort ce que vous faites
lorsque vous êtes avec une personne ou
une autre personne vous choisissez
finalement un peu votre personnalité
mais c'est étrange quand même c'est pas
normal c'est pas possible comme ça de
dire au bout maintenant je vais être un
peu moins drôle oh bah maintenant je
veux être un peu plus drôle c'est
impossible
ce que vous faites réellement c'est
juste que vous le laisser percevoir vous
le laisser transparaître vous avez cette
capacité est drôle mais vous allez là
présenté qu'à certains moments c'est une
notion qui est étrange parce que ça
signifie que vous avez tous tous les
sentiments vous mais que vous ne pouvez
pas tous les exprimer avec la même
intensité
et c' est une notion qui est
intéressante parce que comment vous
parvenez à passer d'une personnalité à
une autre d'un seul coup
parce qu'il ya des moments où deux
milieux se rencontrent je reprends la
question de ma petite amie ou de votre
petit copain vous êtes ensemble et vous
vous dites tiens on va aller manger à la
maison
bon ça se passe plus ou moins bien ça
dépend des personnes mais certains sont
contents d'aller rencontrer vos parents
alors vous êtes avec votre petite amie
vous arrivez devant la porte vous la
tenez dans vos dans vos bras la porte
s'ouvre et là qu'est ce qui se passe là
vous avez ce moment vous vous dites je
suis avec ma petite amie
je suis avec ma famille et vous créez
instinctivement une nouvelle
personnalité qui mélange un peu les deux
mais pour parvenir à créer ce
basculement
comme je vous le dis vous ne pouvez pas
d'un seul coup sélectionner les
sentiments vous allez juste changer
votre apparence et c'est là dessus que
je voudrais insister aujourd'hui comment
parvenir à présenter une personnalité à
travers son apparence
je vais me baser sur une une expérience
du théâtre j'ai fait environ neuf années
de théâtre avec des profs qui était très
bon j'ai eu l'occasion de travailler
avec des étudiants pour faire un petit
peu théâtral utc
mais j'ai un prof qui m'a marqué dans ma
vie un jour il m'a dit il a dit au
groupe
on va faire une séance particulière on
va prendre une heure de notre temps on
va s'asseoir sur un banc et on va
regarder les gens passer ça vous fait
pas rêver
alors je me retrouve là assis sur un
banc et je regarde les gens passent et
il ya une route il ya un pont je regarde
les gens passer comme ça une heure on
dit pas grand chose on est là et à la
fin mon professeur se tourne vers moi et
me dit alors julien tu as compris là je
vous avoue je suis embêté j'avais pas
tout à fait compris donc ce que je fais
c'est que je me tourne vers mes autres
camarades et ils ont l'air aussi
perplexes comme moi je me sens rassuré
non j'ai pas bien compris
alors mon prof il reprend mdi il ya deux
personnes qui marchaient sur ce pont
deux personnes en noir elle était trop
loin pour que tu vois leur visage
elle était trop loin pour tu sache ce
qu'elles ressentent et mais qu'est ce
que t'en as pensé alors là je me dis bon
bah le premier il avait l'air un peu
penché en avant il se dépêchait sûrement
qu'il fallait qu'il aille au travail il
n'avait pas l'air sûre de lui un peu à
et santé le poids du de la pression quoi
s'est il allait pas bien alors que
l'autre qui allait dans l'autre sens au
contraire le torse un peu bombé il
avancé comme ça il avait l'air sûr de
lui un vrai homme d'affaires angie bah
tu as tout compris
tu es incapable de différencier ces deux
personnes
ces deux personnes elles sont identiques
finalement elles sont habillées en noir
pas de visage mais rien que par leur
paraître tu peux imaginer une histoire
le grand travail de l'acteur s'est pas
de changer sa manière de penser
c'est de contrôler les émotions qui va
transmettre à son public ses émotions
qui forment votre personnalité et par
votre corps vous pouvez exprimer
différentes choses
je prendrai un exemple tout simple et
des personnes qui ont une tendance à
s'inquiéter de tout et de rien cette
personne elle est assise sur sa chaise
et là qu'est ce qu'elle voit une narine
eu qu'est ce qui est fait une araignée
écrit oui vous vous ne voyez pas
l'araignée vous vous ne voyez que cinq
secondes de sa vie et vous vous dites oh
ça c'est encore une personne peureuse
c'est pas une personne peureuse elle a
peur des araignées
elle est peut-être arrivé au fort bon
toujours est il que cette personne c'est
pas sa personnalité mais vous avez
imaginé ça perdra sa personnalité et là
où c'est très fort c'est que ce que vous
faites en contrôlant votre corps en
contrôlant votre apparence si je me
positionne de manière un peu plus
sérieuse si c'est possible je me
redresse comme légèrement le torse appui
stable je comble lorsque je n'ai pas
envie bon comme m et là vous dites il
ressemble presque à un prof sans aucune
critique envers les professeurs
mais ce qui signifie que j'ai réussi
encore une fois à donner une nouvelle
impression juste à travers mon corps
mais ce que j'ai appris au théâtre c'est
que l'acteur n'est jamais aussi bon que
lorsqu'il porte un costume
pourquoi oui oui c'est vrai le costume
ça donne une image nous nos rues nos
identités envoyant un costume vous dites
tac je sais qui c'est je connais sa
personnalité il a des jeans troués allez
hop c'est un hippie certains font des
raccourcis comme ça mais là où c'est
plus fort c'est qu'il ya pas besoin
d'être acteur pour utiliser le costume
et changer de personnalité
il n'y a pas si longtemps de ça il y
avait le gala l'utc lors le gala pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas c'est une
une soirée un qui se passe à chantilly
où des étudiants qui ont l'habitude de
boire du jus d'orange en soirée vont au
gala mettre un costume et boivent du jus
d'orange
voilà alors jusqu'à là normalement rien
ne change on a toujours les mêmes
personnes
pourtant la plupart d'entre vous et je
reconnais en plus ce qu'ils étaient au
gala ah oui à l'utc vous promet avec
votre sweat à capuche votre démarche
lente
vous traînez on a l'impression que vous
êtes tous des dépressifs bon bah dont
une partie d'entre vous mais lorsque
vous arrivez au gala lorsque vous mettez
votre costume
vous n'êtes pas des acteurs pourtant à
nouveau cette envie de bombay son torse
à nouveau c'est d'assurance dans la voix
c'est incroyable vous avez changé vos
vêtements et ça a changé
immédiatement vos dettes à l'esprit
alors pour passer d'une personnalité à
une autre il faut juste contrôler
l'image que vous renvoyez votre
personnalité elle est complexe
votre personnalité elle est multiple et
en fonction de la situation
à vous de sélectionner les éléments vous
laisserez paraître par vos vêtements par
votre attitude
c'est un point qui paraît classique
lorsque vous allez en entretien
d'embauché
vous savez bien que vous n'allez pas
montré tout votre personnalité vous
changez vos vêtements
vous changez votre personnalité
à peu près mais dans la vie de tous les
jours vous pouvez faire ça vous pouvez
pas revenir à sentir votre corps un des
premiers exercices du théâtre c'est de
se détendre
on se détend et on sent l'air qui passe
sur son corps pourquoi on fait ça pas
juste parce qu'on aime sentir l'air
passé sur notre corps aucun sens non
parce que vous prenez conscience de
l'impact qu'a votre corps sur
l'environnement en l'occurrence au vu de
ma taille pas trop d'impact sur
l'environnement
mais certains d'entre vous une carrure
un peu plus imposante qui leur permet
d'avoir un impact plus puissant sur
l'environnement hélas une fois que vous
savez que votre doigt gauche il est plus
longue votre boîte droit ça change tout
ça paraît en tout changé pour vous ok
petite question
petite question est-ce que actuellement
vous pensez que vous êtes capable de
bien vous contrôlez ça évite alors
répondez en l'espace de trois secondes à
la question suivante une question simple
vos mains vous savez exactement la
position de vos moments là si vous le
demande
non non vous pensez que vous savez ah
oui j'ai la main sur ma tête se dit le
jeune homme en haut à gauche c'est vrai
il a la main sur ta tête
sauf qu'il sait pas si son petit doigt
et plus repliée que son index ou son
pouce la personne qui a les doigts
croisés c'est pas si elle a mis le petit
doigt de la main gauche en dessous ou le
petit doigt de la main droite en dessous
et tous ces petits détails
une fois que vous parviendrez à les
contrôler vous pourrez vous adapter à
n'importe quelle situation
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]